the task of making order victorious over
chaos or randomness if you take this
seriously you will look upon it as
warfare Alan Watts was a 20th century
British American philosopher born in
1915 he's renowned for his wit eloquence
and success in translating and infusing
Eastern philosophy into the Western
world wasas regarded as being greatly
responsible for the popularization of
Buddhist and Zen principles in the West
inspiring the beat and hippie movements
in the United States during the 60s and
70s and causing major cultural shifts
away from traditional Western values
during his life before dying in 1973 at
age 58 Watts published over 25 books and
articles on various Western and Eastern
theories and was the first to write a
best-selling book on Buddhism entitled
the way of Zen published in 1957 Watts
his unique ability to understand
conceive and translate complex
alternative philosophies into practical
digestible language makes it clear why
he is one of the most enjoyed and
influential philosophers in recent
history Watts is interest in Eastern
philosophy stemmed from his childhood
enjoyment of Chinese and Japanese
storybooks as well as his affinity with
Eastern aesthetic he found that things
like light color and nature were shown
and profoundly beautiful and provoking
waves within Eastern art and he wondered
what it was that allowed these artists
to see and consider the world with such
lucidity Watts was born in what is now
South East London and was initially
raised Christian however during Watts is
developing younger years he began to
find that Christianity's methods of
understanding and dealing with life left
him unappeased unfulfilled and often
with more problems than solutions in
Watson's mind Christianity did not
attempt in any real sense to answer
things like what the true nature of the
universe is what the self is what the
meaning of life is and how to deal with
it all rather Christianity appeared more
interested in studying and maintaining
history and remained firmly transfixed
on the idea that there is some
tyrannical like God figure controlling
everything this idea of an authority
figure controlling the universe was both
unappealing and insensible to Watts and
so in combination with his growing
fondness and curiosity with the eastern
aesthetic he would embark on his journey
into Buddhism
what drew Watts further into Buddhism
was that in Buddhism rather than a
tyrannical like god controlling
everything with some rational or moral
intention there is a universal
consciousness which everything is an
interconnected and interdependent part
of a singular essence to life that
follows its own nature with no boss
every object and every person is merely
an expression of this universal nature
following the nature of itself for the
mere sake of itself Watts found this
concept to be far more reasonable humane
and useful to the experience of life as
Watts would study consider and practice
Eastern ideas like this one he found
that he experienced a certain bliss in
their realization often regarded as
enlightenment or awakening life became
richer anxieties and fears reduced if
not disappeared and peace and connection
with nature blossomed it was this that
Watts wanted to share with the Westerner
an individual whom Watts felt deeply
needed a way out or in
depending on where he stood with a
distinctively diverse background in
understanding of both Western and
Eastern worlds from a cultural
standpoint Watts found that much of the
Western world was intensely alienated
and conflicted often obsessed with
status wealth consumption and success in
being right or the best yet even when
one was successful in the Western ideal
of success they still appeared to remain
lost and disconnected from themselves
their fellow human and nature itself the
idea that a successful business a new
luxury product sold or bought a higher
status a social power or anything alike
could resolve the human experience of
isolation anxiety and vulnerability was
exceptionally foolish in Watsons mind
furthermore it appeared that the Western
religious idea of an absolute morality
and an authoritative God did not really
assist the westerner and his or her
ability to resolve these behaviors or
help discover any spiritual essence in
themselves rather it only further detach
them from the physical of metaphysical
world but making them a subject of
everything instead of a part of
everything the principles of Zen and
watch's teachings diverged rather
significantly as humans we have a very
peculiar consciousness that is aware of
what it is perceiving and furthermore
identifies with its awareness this
self-identification is generally
regarded as ego and as a result of our
ego we tend to feel as though we are
detached from what we are observing that
if there is an i or me of
serving then I must not be what I am
observing that my internal must be
separate from my external Watts would
often refer to this as the sense that we
are an ego in a bag of skin however in
Zen in Watsons teachings this concept
and feeling is not only incorrect but it
is the source of most of our alienation
anxiety suffering and subsequent
animosity with the knowledge that we
will die that things will change that
stuff will dissolve how can we derive
any sense of meaning or connection to
life by chaining our sense of self to
these things to our body to our personal
identity to our stuff to our status one
of if not the most fundamental principle
in Zen and Watson's teachings is the
idea that attempts to resolve this
problem the idea that we are none of
these things that we tend to identify
with but instead we are everything and
everything is us human and nature go
together as one linked inexorably in
infinitely just as noise can't exist
without silence just as light can exist
without darkness our internal cannot
exist without our external and our
experience cannot exist without our non
experience or death everything needs
everything else in order to be anything
at all watts would often define this
using the term organism environment
meaning we are not an organism in an
environment but we are an organism and
an environment simultaneously we are but
a feature of the whole and thus we are
the whole for Watts the illusion that
much of the Western world has and
continues to live in is that our
thoughts are exempt from the laws of the
universe that we have a separate
volition detached from nature and our
thoughts and actions occur voluntarily
and can impose themselves on nature
however for Watts the truth is that our
brain and our consciousness are not
exempt or separate not from the cause
and effect process of the universe and
not from the laws that everything
operates on within the Watson Zen school
of thought success in life is not to
change the world or to make a certain
amount of wealth or to surpass anyone
and status or power or anything of that
sort but the ultimate goal and success
in life is to become deeply synchronized
with nature itself to realize that your
behavior is one with the behavior of the
rest of the world a person is in fact
nature itself and so a person cannot
choose to change or influence nature
because even what appears to be a human
effect on
nature is only in essence a nature
effect on nature which is to say
everything is just nature playing the
game of nature with us and through us
like a river that flows without choosing
to or how to we humans move and act
without choosing to or how to we did not
choose to be a human or the kind of
human we are we did not choose the
conditions of the human body or mind we
simply express the nature of the
universe through them and the
achievement of Zen is to flow freely
without choosing acknowledging that one
is and has always been without choosing
to accept this and overcome one's ego is
no small feat it is to destroy one sense
of self-importance which is of course
very important to the thing that
believes and wants so very badly to be
important but the irony is that perhaps
what we think we want is not what we
need perhaps thinking we are more or
less important than anything or anyone
is not all that helpful for the
experience of life perhaps alternatively
realizing one's unimportance as the
potential to actually open up the door
to a whole new realm of meaningfulness
and enjoyable Ness like an artist in a
state of flow instead of forcing nature
we synchronize with it and perform life
with fluidity and ease of course Watts
is not without criticism nor are the
Eastern philosophies that he
communicated and derived many of his
ideas from it is reasonable to find some
of watch's teachings and translations to
be either confusing or fuzzy for ease up
against a very difficult opponent be it
the very thing we have been conditioned
and wired to identify life with even
four Watts himself it is fair to say
that the ideas he shared were not easy
and did not resolve all the challenges
of being human for him according to
those who knew him he was not without
struggle in her conflict or vice perhaps
his take on life is accurate and
complete or perhaps it is not and
perhaps that is not the point at this
time in our evolution we can only really
speculate what the true nature of
everything is there is no answer at the
back of the book that we can peek at
when things get confusing however that
does not mean that efforts and attempts
at speculating and understanding our
spiritual essence is without value
perhaps it is not the exact accuracy of
any philosophical idea that is important
what the idea can do for us for many
watts as ideas and offerings have and
continue to radically shift how they see
and experience life and a positive
practical
that Christianity and other traditional
Western ideologies continue to overlook
it is not only what Watts said but also
how he said it and who he said it to in
part Watson's fame can be attributed to
his unique ability to translate and
communicate a way out of the cycle of
consumption anxiety and alienation in a
part of the world that has and continues
to severely suffer from these things for
Watts and those who agree with him his
teachings suggest very comforting and
useful ideas of life that fundamentally
there are no mistakes no failures no
successes no good or bad things rather
there are just things that happen that
contrast with other things that happen
that life is not a contest with winners
and losers but an endless game of
back-and-forth that we are not separate
from everything but we are an expression
of everything forever linked with what
has and will always be and that we don't
need to take things quite so seriously
we're an ordinary person sees a battle
an extraordinary person sees a
cooperation a dance as Watts would often
call it and there is no real point to a
dance other than to mystify and
entertain which is to say everything and
everyone is all working together at once
to mystify and entertain to express the
single thing that is universal
consciousness that is life and here we
are in the stance with an ability to
form reason trying to make sense of this
apparently senseless dance and our
attempts we become confused and seek
better meaning better justification
better understanding we overanalyze and
take ownership in this dance in order to
compensate for its elusiveness we
struggle to accept it for what it is but
perhaps there is no better sense to
anything than senselessness for in the
senselessness there is wonder
mystification and entertainment and
perhaps it is this idea that remains
true no matter what we believe in life
whether we agree with Watts Zen
Christianity or any of the other
countless religions and ideologies we're
almost certainly wrong or incomplete in
our understanding and so for now perhaps
the best we can do is to try and enjoy
the dance for what it is in all of its
senselessness and remember that the only
thing that could be bad is to take it
seriously Alan Watts
[Music]
you